millions of Americans expected to hit
the roads this week and as holiday
travel kicks off we're finally seeing a
break in those gas prices Madison
Kimbrough joins us live near Rainbow and
Flamingo tonight with a look at what
this means for holiday plans Madison
we're currently at the Rebel Gas Station
right near Flamingo and you can take a
look behind me as these gas prices are
low which is positive news ranges from
360 to 370 a gallon depending on how you
pay a much needed change from just a
couple months ago where we were seeing
Nevada gas prices above the five dollar
Mark AAA reporting that Nevada's current
average for regular gas is just over
four dollars a gallon with Las Vegas
being just under at 3.97 now the highest
recorded average price for gas in Nevada
was in June and that was almost
5.68 a gallon we spoke to locals today
who share how the decrease in gas prices
has impacted their lives especially now
that it's the holiday season
I have family in California it
definitely makes it a lot easier to go
out there and see them and just driving
around town overall and it just gives us
a lot of Hope going into the new year
2023 I'm hoping for more of this
locals are sharing that because of the
decrease in costs they find themselves
filling up their tanks all the way
instead of what many people did this
summer like myself which was to fill up
just enough to get by for a couple of
days Nevada is still ranked as having
the third highest gas prices in the
nation that's behind Hawaii and
California now currently the national
average for regular gas is 315 a gallon
reporting near Rainbow and Flamingo
Madison Kimbrough 8 News Now